a
500 millions $ pour moderniser
les installations
Le plan prévoit une baisse
progressive des émissions
d'arsenic au cours
des cinq prochaines années,
fixé par Québec. La compagnie at
qu'il n'y pas de solution
sur la t
la norme provinciale
de 3 nanogrammes partout
à Rouyn-Noranda.
CLAUDE BÉLANGER, chef,rerererere
- Présentement, le projetqu'on i
nous amène au 15 nanogrammes tel
que mentde l'Environnement plust
cette semaine. Mais c'est
certain qu'on n'arrête pas là.
On va toujours continuer
les performances.- Cette annoncé
ce médecin urgentologue de
Rouyn-Noranda, qui des actio des
rapides.- On fait un compromis r
arriver à un compromis. Ça va
nous prendre cinq ans pour est
un compromis. Je veux dire,
un momenl faut être
sérieux. La santé des gens,
c'est pas juste des mots.
se fassent rapidement pour
qu'on arrive à 15 beaucoup
plus rapidement que ça.
- La députée de Québec solidaire
a l'impression que la Fonderie
Horne et le gouvernement
caquiste se sont entendus,
derrière des portes closes pour
déterminer la cibl-THERRIEN
porte-parole de QS
- Là, on est dans une optique
où la CAQ semble dire : bien,
dites-nous de combien
vous pouvez diminuer
de pollution, puis c'est ça
qu'on vander.
- Pour François Legault,
le plan proposé répond aux
exigences de la santé publique.
- À 15 nanogrammes, la santé
public dit : c'est sécuritai
Et on est à l'étape de consulter
la population.
- À la Ville de Rouyn-Noranda,
la mairesse aurait voulu un plan
plus précis à long terme.
DIANE DA
mairesse de Rouyn-Noranda
- On peut comprendre qu'il y
aurait un délai peut-être
supplémentaire, mais on aurait
aimé voir ce plan ou avoir
des informations sur ce plan
à long terme pour l'atteinte
du 3 nanogrammes.
- Le syndicat des
de la Fonderie Horne accueille
toutefois ce plan avec
soulagement puisqu'il met fin
à une période d'incertitude.
STÉPHANE LARENTE, prés, Syndicat
des travailleurs, Mine Noranda
- Oui, il y avait des
inquiétudes pour leur emploi.
C'est évident. Surtout que
le ministère puis le ministre
ont été assez clairs là-dessus,
qu'ils ne tassaient pas
une fermeture possible.
- La direction de Glencore dit
être en pourparlers avec
le gouvernement du Québec pour
obtenir une aide financière
cadre de ce projet
de transformation, sans
toutefois vouloir s'avancer
sur un chiffre précis.
Ici Marc-André Landry,
Radio-Canada, Rouyn-Noran